so my pitch to you is that the problem
of democracy is actually that democracy
is one of the easiest forms of political
system to kind of hollow out from the
inside and as you said I've got a book
that's just come out called how to rig
an election when we started doing the
research for that book we thought we
were going to find relatively
significant problematic levels of
electoral manipulation around the world
but sort of 2025 percent what we
actually found is really striking
Stander's we're talking about something
like every other election that is being
held in the world today having
significant manipulation of one kind or
another we're talking about elections
that on average are such poor quality in
some parts of the world that were
actually seeing the opposition win only
one in ten elections that are organized
in other words elections that have
effectively stopped challenging
authoritarians
challenging poor leaders kicking the
bums out but actually served to
legitimate the existing distribution of
power those fantastic stories that we
find in the book of the way these
elections are being manipulated a great
one is for Madagascar where Marlo
Ravalomanana who's a very sort of famous
leader in the country a yogurt magnate
made his money in dairy he wanted to win
the election easily his opposition
leader was outside of the country he
decided that the best way to stop him
from actually competing in the election
were simply that every time he was
flying to the country keep in mind it's
an island he closed all of the airports
unilaterally right the guy never managed
to get into the country he couldn't
submit his papers he wasn't on the
ballot paper the election on the day was
pretty good quality why because you
don't need to worry about the election
on the day if you've excluded you're
most likely rival so on the day the
election was pretty free and fair what
happened international observers decided
that the election was good enough to get
a rubber stamp Ravalomanana not only
retained the presidency but with the
support of the international community
so my pitch here is the problem is not
so much democracy but that we have
allowed democracy to be hollowed out of
meaning and it's not just that this is
happening in far-flung tin-pot
dictatorships that you might think about
in other parts of the world post
communist Europe sub-saharan Africa Asia
Latin America where recently for example
we could talk about the rigging of the
election in Venezuela it's not just that
democracy is being hollowed out in those
places it's also at risk of being
hollowed out in the United States and
the United Kingdom as well the classic
example in the United States is it as
many of you will know we have seen
massive processes of gerrymandering
whereby essentially leaders get to pick
who votes for them rather than the other
way around
in other words we see places in the
United States where we actually get
people who are able to actually select
the people voting for them by
distributing constituency boundaries in
that way and what that means is that we
actually see an awful lot of elections
both in the UK in the US that are
effectively uncompetitive excluding
large portions of the electorate from
the political process so my argument is
that we don't need to abandon democracy
but we need a process of democratic
renewal
you